[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous je suis très
content de vous retrouver vous êtes mes
7 mercenaires et je vous aime
[Musique]
et maintenant la messieurs j'accueille
le député de la France insoumise de
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est Alexis Corbière
c'est pareil ça va Alexis
pourquoi cette chanson
excellente question
bravo mais j'ai du respect pour ce
personnage
historique dans un pays
qui était le boucher qui torturait déjà
par rapport à d'autres pays qui sont
dans la région premièrement le droit à
l'éducation voilà la santé que vous le
vouliez ou non est une réalité et pour
finir pour finir et pour finir sur Che
Guevara votre histoire là notamment la
semaine dernière il y a qu'un jour vous
avez la parole
c'est très contesté il s'appelle Jacobo
macho vert il y en a même qui conteste
la Shoah
est un sujet suffisamment sérieux on a
le droit non mais pas plus on a le droit
d'être critique par rapport à Cuba sans
pour autant ce que raconte ma chose de
dire que Guevara lui-même allait dans
les prisons pour un signe des gens ça
c'est pas vrai
il y avait pas il y habite dans la dans
la dans la dans le personnage
on parle de quelque chose la révolution
est en 59 on parle des années 60 et le
master en question est né en 57 donc il
avait 5-6 ans il était personnellement
mais ça avec son père
les gens dans les prisons les
homosexuels étaient massacrés c'est un
faux
à cause d'une chanson parce qu'il faut
dire à nos amis téléspectateurs qui nous
ont peut-être pas au courant c'est que
vous êtes marié tous les deux bah oui
son mari
ils ont des enfants je dois dire que
évidemment il y a un petit questionnaire
là qui vient qui a un petit peu
intime un peu privé mais ensuite on va
parler politique on commence avec le bio
quiz
[Musique]
vous êtes prêts attention café Alexis
Corbière quand il était enfant il a
manifesté pour la gratuité des cantines
il était en fond de cœur
il a fugué pour aller voir Francis
Lalanne en concert et il a fait une
grève de la fin après cette pris un
râteau toutes les règles
[Applaudissements]
il a pas la raie au milieu c'est très
bizarre
confirmation etc
en fait mais plus sérieusement vous
évoquez Francis Lalanne c'est j'adorais
Francis lalanade des cheveux longs moi
j'avais les cheveux
comment s'appelait le doudou du petit
Alexis Corbière nounours
Colargol Pépito ou Jean-Luc Pépito
[Applaudissements]
Alexis Corbière qui mériterait une rue à
son nom
Luc Mélenchon ou ameli
attends mais il y a pas de rue
Robespierre il y a un métro Robespierre
c'est à Montreuil dans ma
circonscription mais c'est une belle
histoire l'histoire de la rue
Robespierre Pascal la libération en 45
quand il y a une majorité municipale
socialiste et communiste c'est une
évidence qui aura il y a une place la
place Saint-Honoré je crois que vous
avez connaissez qui va devenir la place
Robespierre il y a unanimité du Conseil
de Paris et quand il y a une majorité
etc et en 51 quand la droite revient
elle redébatise ce qui aurait dû être
une place Robespierre et moi je pense
que quel que soit ce qu'on pense de ce
personnage je pense que ça fait partie
ça fait partie des grandes figures de
l'histoire de France il y a une rue
Adolphe Thiers à Paris par exemple on
est d'accord non mais Adolphe Thiers qui
a massacré 40000 communards il y a
beaucoup de personnages et moi je crains
qu'on perde la mémoire de révolution
française moi j'ai été prof d'histoire
aujourd'hui souvent quand je discute
avec nous nos élèves ils connaissent
plus le nom d'un seul révolutionnaire
ils ont plein de sang sur les mains tous
ces gens alors que la Révolution
française il y a des vrais héros il y a
Mirabeau il y a la feuillette Camille
Desmoulins
il rentre au Panthéon il est chassé du
Panthéon quand on s'aperçoit qu'il était
financé par le roi c'était un corrompu
comme on fait pas c'est peut-être ça
peut être votre modèle mais Robespierre
c'est l'incorruptible bon moi je préfère
encore
de quelle étiquette politique est le
maire qui a marié Raquel Garrido et
Alexis quand vous avez des informations
c'est terrible FRONT NATIONAL France
insoumise Parti socialiste les
républicains ou chassent Pêche Nature et
traditionnel
non c'est pas vrai c'est que
Jean-François Corbière c'est son cousin
il est Front national il peut rien
aujourd'hui il n'était pas là
personne n'est parfait
212 les époux se doivent mutuellement
fidélité de secours assistance bravo et
puis voilà
Jean-François ses enfants soit il est
pas responsable de son cousin
les réciproquements
avec qui avec si Corbières partage-t-il
son arbre généalogique Emmanuel Macron
Gilles Williams golden Marine Le Pen ou
M Pokora Macron
généalogiste en découvert en fait que
vous aviez un ancêtre commun Adam Pujol
mais je pense sincèrement que à 400 ans
on est peut-être tous cousins
quand il était jeune
Julien Dray rêvait d'être baron de la
drogue
vendeur de tapis volant
commandant de bateau ou président de la
République
j'habitais dans une ville s'appelait
Oran il y avait à Port des gros bateaux
et ils sont fascinés
à propos d'Emmanuel Macron c'est une
pépite il a fait un sans faute c'est un
garçon brillant
ou c'est un homme sincèrement de gauche
un garçon
les quatre
[Applaudissements]
vrais
en août 2015 comment Julien Dray
s'est-il déchiré le tendon d'Achille en
courant après sa femme
à présent taxi encore à présent le chien
ou en courant après Emmanuel Macron
comment va ce chien il va très bien
qui s'appelle Akita
au Japon comment le père de Roselyne la
surnommait-elle quand elle était enfant
Roro mimine Mowgli bouclette grande
gueule Mowgli Google comment tu sais
bravo tu sais ça fait alors pourquoi
parce que vous avez une tête à vous
appeler Mowgli mais non mais je trouvais
ça
original je me dis tiens votre père
était un mec bien ouais
quel était le surnom de Roselyne
Bachelot quand elle était scout de guide
fuck hilarant visant soyeux c'était Dave
castor bégayant ou Fouine babillarde toi
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe là je suis
bon là tu as des choses à nous dire on a
dit que ça reste entre nous on avait vu
on a bu voilà c'est comme ça
c'est fait comme avant et pas comme un
bison soyeux que s'est-il passé lorsque
Roselyne Bachelot a pris la parole pour
défendre le PACS à l'Assemblée nationale
en 1998 Simone Veil est venu la soutenir
des députés de droite ont quitté la
salle Roselyne a regagné son banc en
pleurs ou Christine Boutin a brandi la
Bible
et je crois que tout dernier sont bonnes
et la bonne séroseline a regagné sont
bonsoir
pour bâtir un projet où chacun et
chacune d'entre nous pourra se retrouver
lui ses enfants ses parents à un moment
ou à l'autre de sa vie car finalement
nous ne reconnaissons ici qu'une
communauté la République
voilà quelqu'un qui a une réelle utilité
sociale vous étiez toute seule là
j'ai pas vraiment pleuré j'étais dans un
état d'émotion intense et j'ai un moment
je me suis dit je vais mettre la tête
dans les mains et puis j'ai repensé à
cette image de Simone Veil mettant sa
tête dans ses mains au moment du débat
sur l'avortement et je me suis dit je ne
peux pas faire une captation d'image ce
serait une sorte de vol médiatique et
donc il faut que je me tienne à ma place
et seulement à ma place qui a répondu
c'est beaucoup plus drôle je me suicide
lorsqu'on lui a demandé ce qu'il ferait
s'il était Roselyne Bachelot pendant 24
heures Henri Guaino Laurent Ruquier
Nicolas Hulot ou hafsatoussi
[Musique]
nous regarde
parmi ces déclarations laquelle est de
Roselyne Bachelot des [__] il y en a
autant en politique qu'à la télé bien
sûr qu'on peut tromper sa femme à
condition de le faire bien ce que j'aime
dans le porno c'est de découvrir des
choses que je n'avais jamais imaginé
toutes des [__]
dans son livre antipathie quel
personnalité est la cible de Gérard
Miller Jean-Luc Lahaye Laurent Gerra
Éric Zemmour Fabrice Luchini
Jean-Jacques Bourdin plan cul ou Michel
Onfray
ça peut être Zemmour
pourquoi chaque Laurent Gerra par
exemple pourquoi parce que c'est un
beauf bravo c'est un beau fruit
quelqu'un qui ne va planter ne peut pas
être tout à fait mauvais
lors des manifs de Mai 68 il a distribué
des paniers gourmands de luxe voler ses
Fauchon il a blessé gravement un
policier il a tagué de Gaulle à poil sur
la Mairie du 2e arrondissement de Paris
il n'était pas à Paris mais en Chine
avec Mao
c'est exact c'est-à-dire que les
gauchistes d'alors qui étaient à la
gauche pour les terrines ont
effectivement attaqué Fauchon qui était
donc cette boutique de luxe ou grosso
modo chaque foie gras allait deux ou
trois sites de l'époque mais c'était un
petit peu plus tard que 68 et on a eu
l'idée après comme Robin des Bois
d'aller distribuer les produits volés
chez Fauchon dans des foyers d'immigrés
dans des foyers de vieux travailleurs
c'était un des titres de gloire que j'ai
d'ailleurs Rolling Stones qui sont
arrivés à Paris à ce moment-là je m'en
souviens parce que c'était pas tout à
fait le même milieu avait rendu hommage
à l'une de nos camarades arrêtez à
l'occasion de cette attaque illégale
c'est vrai mais vous reconnaîtrez quand
même comment on reconnaît l'inégalité
oui au lycée comment Gérard Miller
parvenait-il à se faire un peu d'argent
en faisant les devoirs de ses camarades
en vendant des histoires cochonnes en
hypnotisant ses camarades ou en
décollant les chewing-gums sous l'État
en hypnotisant comment tu le sais parce
que je sais qu'il a fait de l'hypnose
avec ça m'intéresse
on se retrouve après la pub avec les
Terriens du dimanche l'émission qui vous
êtes à vous faire votre opinion à dessus
[Musique]
salut le serveur bienvenue dans
l'émission qui vous êtes à vous faire
votre opinion ce soir face au sept
mercenaires Alexis Corbière
avec Iron girl Natacha Polony pour
détourner un avion il faut être dedans
elle est là Raquelle Garrido alors je
lui demandais un peu d'argent de poche à
tes parents elle avait déjà créé sa
boîte à tout si
c'est la chroniqueuse la plus élégante
de la télé Kashmir Monia
il est végétarien mais il dévore les
politiques Franck Olivier Gisbert
l'avocat qui se défend très bien
lui-même Gil Williams Goldman
jeune et jolie comme lui
alors pour notre invité sur rouge j'ai
deux slogans vous allez me dire celui
que vous préférez Alexis le premier
c'est insoumis sauf à quel
ou alors Alexis Corbière la gauche qui
n'est pas de droite
vous préférez lequel non mais je vais
choisir le premier même si Raquel est
comme pour l'égalité entre nous deux
très bien et vous avez un sampleur aussi
invité
j'adore la chanson française il y avait
pas dans la chanson française dans le
truc pour
Sardou Lénine réveille-toi ils sont
devenus fous par exemple
si cela aussi
l'intérieur du dimanche le groupe on est
vraiment de fortune et le hashtag
et on commence avec l'invité fil rouge
face aux sept mercenaires
[Applaudissements]
dans chacun une question à vous poser à
tout vous avez une question à poser
Alexis Corbière oui monsieur Corbière
j'aimerais qu'on regarde quelques-unes
de vos interventions politiques et puis
je vous pose la question après
[Musique]
le maillot que je porte aujourd'hui
c'est celui de l'Olympique au courtois
c'était le club de mon ami Antoine j'ai
fait des courses ce matin Monsieur le
Premier Ministre elles sont là et voilà
ce que vous supprimez tous les mois par
les plus démunis le président Mélenchon
vous le montre elle sent à votre
disposition et aussi à la disposition de
la député aux petits délaissé un instant
les belles paroles ne me répondez même
pas pas un mot pas une phrase je n'en
serais pas outré faites simplement un
geste sortez le carnet de chair c'est
Monsieur le Député
franchement c'est saoulant quoi oui
c'est saoulant on vous dérange et bah
débrouillez-vous entre vous nous on s'en
va
allez bonsoir
merci monsieur le Président Mélenchon
j'ai souvent l'impression que la
politique est un cirque quand je vois
ces images me le dis encore un peu plus
j'ai envie de vous demander c'est sortir
au manège que qu'on peut voir ne
déferve-t-elle pas vos propos votre
combat que je respecte et surtout ne
servent-elles pas à masquer la pauvreté
de certains de vos raisonnements
politiques alors honnêtement vous avez
le droit de pas du tout être d'accord
avec ce que je dis je comprends et même
de trouver ça peut-être à l'arrivée
pauvre ça me touche mais ceci dit je
vais vous dire ça fait 7 mois que je
suis élu j'ai fait 658 interventions moi
à l'Assemblée nationale et je suis pas
le meilleur parmi mes copains j'ai
présenté soutenu avec mes amis 2001 à
Mondement donc d'accord donc on a
énormément bossé on est parmi les
députés les plus travailleurs surtout
les sujets surtout les ballons après il
y a des moments parce qu'on est dans une
société médiatique j'assume le fait et
quelque part ce que j'ai fait sur les
pattes montrer ce que Rob dans 5 euros
je vais vous dire un truc j'en suis fier
bien sûr le président de Rugy de
l'Assemblée m'a reproché ça il a même il
m'a même menacé d'une amende et puis
après il a sanctionné mon ami Rufin on
est sur le fil du rasoir il faut pas
trop en faire sinon je comprends que
vous me disiez si la seule chose qu'on a
à dire c'est des maillots de foot et des
pâtes vous êtes en droit de me dire
franchement ça vaut pas un clou mais
quand je considère que ce gouvernement a
fait un budget qui a rendu au sang
contribuable les plus riches du pays 1,5
millions d'euros et qu'à l'inverse on va
taper sur les APL qui concernent les 6,2
millions de Français les plus modestes
leur supprimer 5 euros par mois je
trouve ça je vous dirai un gros mot
dégueulasse et j'ai voulu l'illustrer
totalement parce que ça beuzé non mais
j'assume s'il a besoin du spectacle
d'ailleurs je suis fier de ce moment là
parce que je me sens que j'ai donné de
la dignité aux gens pour qui 5 euros
bonne question pour osez toujours une
question
Roselyne on va tous dire il y a pas
longtemps on a fêté la fête des amoureux
donc si vous devez choisir
vous préférez un Valentin Wauquiez de
gauche ou un Valentin Macron de droite
en fait je ne couche avec l'un ni avec
l'autre ah non il faut choisir
on va leur dire ou pas
parce qu'il aime les vieilles alors
formulaire
vas-y il m'a baignant ah alors Mowgli
j'ai une question mais il se connaissent
on se connaît bien vous avez déclaré
François Fillon est toujours mon ami
mais il m'a je lui en veux beaucoup
alors ma question c'est il vous a pas
rendu l'argent également ou comment ça
se passe
non c'est un sujet dont je ne parle pas
j'ai à chaque fois qu'on me le demande
je cite la phrase de Robert Desnos
grand poète juifs français mort dans le
camp de tes résines et qui disait un
jour je te décevrai et ce jour-là
j'aurais besoin de toi
Gilles William quelle question avez-vous
à poser à notre ami Géraldine à dire le
vrai j'étais étonné de vous savoir chez
les insoumis moi pour moi vous étiez un
psychanalyste médiatique raffiné et
installé et vous voir en compagnie de
gens un peu plus frustre façon madame
Garrido façon monsieur Ruffin ou
d'autres je vous trouve un petit peu
déclassé vous êtes peut-être la caution
BCBG des insoumis mais la question que
je voudrais vous poser où vous situez au
sein de la gauche caviar tendance béluga
ou tendance et brouillard
je dois vous dire que si on faisait une
échelle de la vulgarité je vous placerai
au sommet donc vous voyez que nous
n'avons pas et les gens que vous avez
cité Ruffin Garrido et je dirais tous
les autres notamment tous les autres
insoumis puisque je ne fais pas partie
de la France insoumise mais je suis un
compagnon de route tous les autres me
semblent infiniment plus raffinés que
ceux qui mangent avec des fourchettes et
des couteaux dans des assiettes comme on
disait à l'époque de porcelaine ou que
sais-je des gens qui ont de bonnes
manières je trouve infiniment plus
vulgaire pour vous dire simplement les
choses le patron du Medef que n'importe
quel ouvrier qui effectivement
[Musique]
vous étiez le jeune grand espoir de la
gauche vous étiez le chouchou de
François Mitterrand enfin franchement
n'importe qui aurait mis beaucoup de
pognon sur vous je vais vous demander
comme ça un peu brutalement mais
aujourd'hui avec l'âge le temps
qu'est-ce qu'a foiré dans notre carrière
pour en arriver là parce que finalement
vous êtes pas comme question
c'est une question c'est une question
qu'on pose à un moment donné
[Musique]
il y a rien qui a foret moi je suis un
militant donc ce qui compte pour moi
c'est mes combats c'est pas ma carrière
peut-être que vous avez du mal à
comprendre ça les uns les autres
peut-être je vous raconte une histoire
le jour François Mitterrand est mort mon
assistant qui était avec moi on était
face à face j'ai dit la fête est finie
pour moi ils vont me faire payer toutes
les années qui viennent de s'écouler
donc vous avez répondu à la question
parce que c'est ça au front le problème
je n'ai pas fait les grandes écoles ça
compte à un moment donné je ne pouvais
pas dans leur monde et je ne veux pas y
être voilà je reste ce que je suis un
militant qui se bat et ce que je veux
c'est que le jour où on fermera mes yeux
on dira ce type et rester fidèle à ce
qu'il a été et c'était peut-être un type
bien ça me suffit voilà c'est bien alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le Parti
socialiste se cherche un nouveau
secrétaire général et c'est pas vous
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé la question
que je me pose aussi vous voyez depuis
plusieurs jours parce que à un moment
donné j'ai dit à tout le monde j'ai
écouté moi je veux bien faire le job
c'est pas le plus facile je suis même
pas certain d'y ouais mais je crois que
j'ai l'expérience l'autorité un
savoir-faire que personne ne conteste et
puis à partir du moment où j'ai dit ça
j'ai vu toute une un appareil se crisper
personne ne répondait aux propositions
que j'ai faites soit au contraire on
disait ah c'est vachement bien ce que tu
as dit mais à ce moment-là tout le monde
s'est mis ensemble pour essayer de
m'empêcher donc à un moment donné je
leur ai dit d'écouter allez vous faire
voir débrouillez-vous tout seul et voilà
à tout votre question à Christophe
Castaner moi c'est pas une question
c'est un constat alors figurez-vous que
quand on vous a vu arriver on s'est dit
mais il a un look absolument incroyable
toujours bien habillé costume impeccable
je vous dis pas tout ça pour faire
sauter mes PV mais on s'est dit on s'est
dit il est sexy il est incroyable vous
avez vu toute la presse à titré voilà en
disant qu'il était presque un dieu du
stade je voulais me frotter
et alors là je me suis dit quand même
comment on peut passer de dieu du stade
au look de Chuck Norris mais alors
non moi je veux comprendre ce qui s'est
passé entre ce moment là et maintenant
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous regardez
cette coupe de cheveux incroyable avec
cette longueur sur la nuque cette
chemise ouverte avec cette chaîne en or
qui brille comme IAM le disait voilà
veste trop grande voilà qu'est-ce qui se
passe même les mains on l'a stressé
excuse-moi c'est pas ça
alors d'abord j'ai gardé la chaîne en or
parce que c'est le cadeau d'anniversaire
de ma maman pour mes 18 ans donc
celle-là elle me quitte pas
ensuite j'avais un coiffeur qui a adoré
la nuque longue version Chris
waddley et donc j'osais pas le contraire
et puis après le pire c'est que
globalement je trouvais ça pas mal
il y a toute une époque où il a failli
mal tourner etc c'est un peu à cette
époque là elle pense que j'ai mal tourné
quand même
Mathieu vous avez rencontré Emmanuel
Macron oh là là mais je vous comprends
pareil
non mais je raconte une histoire vraie
ok ça sans déconner j'écris dans Charlie
Hebdo et dimanche dernier il y avait les
trois ans les commémorations des trois
ans donc on était tous devant les locaux
de Charlie là où il y a tuerie et donc
on dépose la germe et la gerbe de fleurs
ça et après donc il y a Emmanuel Macron
qui arrive avec sa femme et Anne Hidalgo
ok Anne Hidalgo je la connais on s'est
rencontré quelques fois il me dit
bonjour Mathieu elle me fait ça va je
vois ça va je suis pas venu en voiture
donc c'est bon
à ce moment-là il y a Brigitte Macron
qui arrive qui est très ému qui est un
larme vraiment donc peut-être qu'elle
est venue en bagnole et et et
là il y a Emmanuel Macron qui arrive et
on vous présente tu dis voilà la
présence qui me présente monsieur Macron
je vous présente et la Manu c'est ce qui
me fait et Montréal il me fait mais je
connais très bien monsieur Madénian
alors je fais ma blague préférée je fais
écouter monsieur je sais pas vous me
rappeler quelqu'un mais je sais pas qui
tu vois comme ça et là il me sert la
main et il me dit on fera les une autre
fois et en partant il me touche les
fesses non ouais parole d'honneur je
suis resté je suis limite amoureux je
vous dis la vérité il m'a eu cercle
[Applaudissements]
je l'ai vu partir j'y crois pas ah mais
par l'honneur je te et je l'ai vu partir
du paiement
il est en Chine avec le président
chinois j'étais jaloux du chinois
c'était les 7 mercenaires passent à
inviter le rouge
l'intérieur de dimanche ont maintenant
carte blanche on passe en zone libre
cette semaine vous nous rapporter une
interview exclusive de Brigitte Bardot
elle est sortie de son silence pour vos
beaux yeux France contact avec elle
facilement parce que je suis un militant
de la cause animale aussi en plus
j'avoue que je l'adore moi c'est
quelqu'un que j'adore c'est quand même
l'incarnation de l'émancipation des
femmes quelqu'un qui a parfois aux yeux
enfin c'est une combattante courageuse
moi je suis vraiment je suis très
admiratif et alors c'est énorme star
connu partout Brésil aux fin fond de
l'Afrique il va y avoir une migration du
statut jeudi 28 septembre une très belle
statue de Milo Manara et puis derrière
tout ça c'est incroyable quand vous
allez chez elle à la Madrague il y a des
embouteillages de bateaux devant un des
touristes avec des avec des jumelles et
tombe en fait ils voient parce que sa
chambre donne sur l'eau en fait elle vit
dans l'eau presque parce que et donc les
gens regardent la reconnaissance
[Applaudissements]
cette ville de Saint-Tropez en fait elle
devrait s'appeler je sais pas bébé ville
Brigitte Bardot ville où je parle sainte
Brigitte ce serait pas mal ça Brigitte
parce qu'au fond Saint-Tropez c'est
Bardot et Bardot c'est Saint-Tropez les
gens ici viennent de partout du monde
entier les Juifs les artistes pour voir
la Madrague la maison de Brigitte Bardot
les lieux où l'été la ponche etc cette
ville c'est Brigitte Bardot il a inventé
vous êtes la grande copine le Logis de
Bardot depuis quand vous la connaissez
je la connais depuis que je fais petite
toute petite vous avez connu toutes ces
histoires laquelle était la plus forte
ces histoires à votre avis Brigitte
de Saint-Tropez et elle à l'époque elle
ajoute pas rentrer chez moi il y a trop
de monde leur petit pas se sont dirigé
vers l'entrée de l'hôtel ils ont sonnait
maman a ouvert la porte et maman a dit
ma petite Brigitte monsieur gatter mais
qu'est-ce que je vais dire aux
journalistes demain matin et Brigitte
qui avait le sens de la répartie lui a
dit Madame Barbier vous ne direz rien on
sera déjà parti à l'étranger
c'est pas
le temps
[Musique]
sur la plage abandonnée
coquillage et crustacés
qui l'eût cru déplore la perte de l'été
la folie Bardot à Saint-Tropez ça vient
d'où c'est dingue
de la folie Bardot moi je suis
tranquille chez moi pas folle du tout
les pizzas
des animaux un dîner du sort des pauvres
gens aussi je prends en compte la misère
sous toutes ses formes et à travers la
misère animale je découvre une misère
humaine je ne connaissais pas des gens
âgés des gens malades des gens seuls des
gens qui
protègent les animaux et qui n'ont même
pas de quoi vivre eux et qui pourtant
protège les animaux alors que des
milliardaires des gros cons qui ont des
yachts des grandes propriétés du pognon
a pu savoir au [__] sans rien pour les
animaux en général
le matin ça commence la révolte commence
le matin
et la révolte pas du tout elle commence
quand je commence à me prendre en compte
avec mon courrier de l'horreur dans
laquelle on vit je suis très remonté
contre les politiques contre les
certains journalistes qui m'entraîner
dans la boue qui continue qui me
traitent de raciste parce que je suis
contre les abattages rituels par exemple
ça me donne mal au cœur j'ai envie de
vomir ce que c'est dégueulasse
sont les étourdures c'est ça
les étourdir et en faire une tradition
ça je ne supporte pas je crois que je
pourrais tuer pour empêcher ce massacre
pour moi c'est la Saint-Barthélémy c'est
massacre des innocents des moutons sont
innocents et on les fait souffrir au nom
de je ne sais quoi d'une connerie qui
est moyenâgeuse et depuis des
millénaires il y a pas du tout
d'évolution Brigitte quand vous vous
retrouvez devant Dieu qu'est-ce que vous
aimeriez qu'il vous dise ah que j'ai pas
perdu mon temps et qu'est-ce que vous
direz vous d'accord je suis bien
contente d'être près de lui parce que un
peu marre de connards voilà c'est pour
ça que vous vous êtes un peu retiré du
monde un peu comme ça on a l'impression
ouais j'ai rien à dire à des gens qui
sont sans intérêt j'ai pas envie
d'écouter leur bêtises genre connerie
donc je préfère être seul c'est
peut-être ça aussi qu'on retient le
mythe cette sorte de mise entre pays de
solitude
ah oui mais je suis très content merci
merci
[Musique]
les années passent mais Brigitte Bardot
ne change pas en fait est-ce qu'il
extraordinaire c'est cette liberté
qu'elle a quand elle est jeune elle a
fait toutes les folies possible
imaginable et ça continue elle dit ce
qu'elle pense comme ça rien à [__] de
rien oui même pas peur voilà c'est ça
que j'aime chez elle et j'aime aussi
évidemment tout ce qu'elle incarne c'est
à dire faut pas oublier l'espèce de ce
qui s'est passé avec les femmes dans ces
années-là quoi elle incarne certaines
anticipation le Front National et
qu'elle vive avec un mec qui est
ostensible
faut arrêter les conneries
qui est de partir de la souffrance
animale pour l'empathie vers la
souffrance humaine bon il y a dans le
mouvement on va dire de la classe
ouvrière etc classique un peu
aujourd'hui le phénomène inverse
c'est-à-dire les gens ils partent de
l'empathie sur la situation humaine mais
comment ça comprendre quand même qu'il
faut avoir voilà il faut avoir une
sensibilité sur les animaux et c'est ça
que Brigitte Bardot avait salué chez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
moi je me reconnais pas du tout
là-dedans parce que pour le coup nous on
est végans dans la famille pour l'Aïd
pour l'Aïd on l'a égorgé une courgette
ça c'est très bien passé
je me reconnais pas dans tes propos
je ne dirai qu'une chose bravo Franck
Olivier Giesbert
et maintenant mesdames messieurs c'est
l'heure des terriens de Tanguy parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame messieurs et on commence avec
notre terrien numéro 1
[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron qui voyage Maroc
Autriche Bulgarie Roumanie c'est pas un
président c'est un guide du routard à
tel point que parfois Brigitte lui met
un marque-page alors là le couple est
allé à Athènes un ou Macron a croisé
Alexis cipras le grec qui a plus
retourné sa veste qu'un sapeur congolais
alors Brigitte était splendide on l'a vu
en blanc le président grec a bouffé des
yeux comme si c'était un dead feta
rouler dans du Vuitton puis en rouge
avec le président grec de plus en plus
liquide à côté puis en bleu après le
décès du président grec dans le coeur à
lâché quand elle lui a fait un clin
d'œil
et c'est là que le drame est arrivé
Macron a dû se dire ce qui se passe à
Athènes reste à Athènes tel un Allemand
qui chez lui traverse sur les clous mais
qui a Pattaya se retrouve avec trois
mineurs sans slip sur les genoux et il a
dit je ne céderai rien au feignant ça
c'est nous bon en tout cas ceux qui le
critiquent puis Benjamin Griveaux l'un
de ses ministres a qualifié les Antibois
travail de névrosées on a élu un gendre
idéal qui sent le savon on se retrouve
avec Joey Starr et ses potes Aurore
Bergé député en marche nous a ensuite
retraités de feignants parce que
certains sont tellement feignants que la
première fois ils ont eu la flemme
d'entendre c'est un quinquennat sm un
même quand vous allez dans un donjon
retrouver un maître dominateur on vous
parle mieux alors en marche c'est un qui
frappe une autre qui mord et le reste
qui insulte c'est la seule bande de
kaïra du 8e arrondissement
allez on part à gauche
avec Jack Lang qui pour la première fois
de sa vie a pris quelqu'un d'autre en
photo et pas lui-même il a bien sûr été
interné à la demande de sa famille
inquiète quand Yannick Jadot d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts avec d'autres bon il
a fait interdire par l'Europe la pêche
électrique ce qui est dommage parce que
les poissons sortaient de la merde déjà
cuit on pouvait directement se mettre à
table c'était pratique enfin lui
forcément il fait rien c'est un verbe
mais nous on n'a pas le temps de
cuisiner donc bref c'est une victoire
pour Jadot un qui a pu parler à un
journaliste au lieu de 0 d'habitude un
monsieur qui bien sûr au contact de
j'adore regarder c'est endormi sur place
en tenant son micro comme s'il était en
train d'interviewer Katsuni
quant à nid d'algo maire de Paris et
bien on a enfin compris à quoi elle sert
à cacher avec sa tête les seins de la
dame du tableau de la Croix elle a
l'existence d'un soutien-gorge alors
astuce elle peut aussi servir de slip au
tableau l'origine du monde ah bah c'est
quand même plus joli comme ça
pour Manuel Valls la semaine a été une
semaine de routine il s'est fait recaler
par la République en marche 4 mois qu'il
essaie de rentrer de techniquement c'est
un témoin de Jéhovah et français
Hollande le petit père de tulle a
commenté à la télé un match de la Ligue
2 il y avait BeIn Sport maintenant on a
has BeIn Sport
[Applaudissements]
bravo côté France insoumise on a on a
manifesté Raquel et Alexis Corbière les
Roméo et Juliette de la feignantise les
Tic et Tac de la névrose ont fait un
selfie un Corbière avec le sourire le
moins naturellement quand un Hidalgo a
appris que Paris avait les JO 2024 alors
que c'était la seule ville en lycée la
belle-mère alors Corbière qui à cause du
soleil a fini la manif tout orange à
faire passer Trump pour Amélie Nothomb à
quelle sorte avec le Chase retrouver
Casimir puis Mélenchon a dit de Macron
nous allons le faire reculer alors faire
reculer un mec en marche donc ça y est
l'autre en plus va se déplacer en moonw
allez partons voir nos ministres
[Musique]
Jean-Michel Blanquer ministre de
l'éducation c'est lui rendu dans une
école maternelle ou un enfant avait
dessiné Emmanuel Macron en train de
vomir des insultes
feignant névrosé communiste et Édouard
Philippe a rencontré Ruth Elkrief qu'il
m’atta même avait enfilé deux bébés
panthères c'est la seule cagole des
pieds alors ensuite il s'est reposé sous
le portrait de Macron et c'est 18 quoi
je suis resté assis une minute trente je
suis un feignant une raclure et il s'est
flageller avec un code du travail
déchirant en 4 bien sûr
allez on part à droite
avec Gérard Larcher président du Sénat
qui a posé la première pierre d'un
hôpital et le pays est ruiné à on le
voit au fait qu'on ne pose même plus des
pierres mais quatre duplos c'est le
problème d'avoir pris un Président si
jeune la France c'est devenu jouer club
les premiers immeubles en pain d'épices
sont en construction et on parle de
l'entrée des kids United au gouvernement
mais c'est pire c'est pire en savoir
puisque regardez les routes s'effondrent
Laurent Wauquiez le petit chaperon rouge
est venu constater les dégâts il a dit
ça me rappelle mon parti oui oui c'est
l'hémorragie il y a plus de gens en ce
moment qui quittent les républicains que
les Syrie Juppé le bons léthargique ne
règle même plus ses cotisations l'âge
sans doute il oublie il faut aussi lui
rappeler toutes les deux heures de faire
pipi et de s'alimenter trois fois par
jour et sont tellement habitués à voir
se barrer les gens regardez que
maintenant vos pieds fait ses réunions à
côté de la porte pour faciliter la
sortie des militants Christian Estrosi
maire de Nice ça lui annonçait
l'interpellation d'une personne qui
avait tagué la mairie il s'agit d'un
député en marche qui depuis 48 heures
n'avait traité personne ni de feignant
ni de névrosées et qui a craqué alors
allez un peu d'international
[Musique]
alors Boris Johnson ministre des
Affaires étrangères britanniques à lui
et bien fait une vidéo où il est apparu
tout débrayé avec les cheveux en pétard
c'est sa marque de fabrique ainsi il
allait à Notre-Dame-des-Landes il se
retrouverait à faire des macramés en pot
de courgette avec les indices enfin en
Allemagne en gala Merkel a mangé alors
je rassure la famille il ne s'agit pas
de Jacques Séguéla au sortir du plan de
soleil c'est juste un sanglier rôti un
Séguéla va bien c'est à dire qu'il
ressemble à ça mais qu'il bouge
enfin enfin Macron manule embrouille
s'est rendu à Saint-Martin sur le tarmac
à Paris il a salué chaque personne une
par une salut fainéant ça va branleur et
toi alors trou de balle ta névrose tu
t'en sors un peu arrivé à Saint-Martin
il a eu envie de crier allez les nulsos
on sort les doigts et hors-construits
mais il a juste dit bonjour c'est bien
que personne ne l'a reconnu alors quand
l'ouragan était sur Saint-Martin il
était en Grèce quand les manifs avaient
lu à Paris il était à Saint-Martin il a
toujours un train de retard conséquence
logique il veut réformer la SNCF c'est à
une semaine sur la terre salut les
clients
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
carte blanche on repasse en zone libre
alors deux mois après l'évacuation de
plus de
2500 migrants à Paris il serait encore
600 à devoir
errer dans les rues de la capitale
entendre d'obtenir une place dans un
centre d'hébergement Gilles William
Goldnadel a suivi le mouvement mais elle
est rencontré on regarde
j'ai voulu voir par moi-même comment ces
gens vivent comment ils boivent comment
ils font leurs besoins comment ils se
lavent donc maintenant je vais vous
montrer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait cinq jours que je n'ai pas mangé
que je ne me suis pas lavé je dois
utiliser les toilettes dans la rue on a
beaucoup de problèmes
c'est pas un endroit pour des hommes
c'est un endroit pour des animaux
nous vivons comme des animaux
ici je me suis dit la France c'est bien
et je suis arrivé là
bon il y a trois toilettes pour je ne
sais pas combien de personnes
et nous ne sommes pas capables de vous
transmettre les odeurs de cet endroit
voilà voilà dans quoi ces gens vivent
[Musique]
figurez-vous qu'à quelques parts de là
où les gens dorment ou sont amassés il y
a un centre où il pourrait être et donc
on va rentrer pour voir pour quelle
raison ils n'y sont pas
monsieur Morel où sommes-nous là alors
ici vous êtes dans la partie halle
d'hébergement du centre de première
accueil des migrants
il y a quelque chose qui me révolte déjà
les gens ne sont pas en surnombre
comment se fait-il que je vois des
grappes humaines dehors mais tout
simplement parce que moi j'ai une
capacité de 400 places et je peux pas en
accueillir plus
est-ce que vous comprenez le la détresse
de ceux qui sont dehors et qui peuvent
pas rentrer tout à fait pourquoi on a
construit ça c'est parce qu'on était
présent dans les campements et qu'on ne
supportait plus ces situations de
détresse terrible la rue n'est pas une
réponse personne ne se satisfait des
conditions de la rue et je ne les
cautionne pas
je suis je suis accablé parce que j'ai
vu accablé par ce que j'ai vu dans la
rue et émerveillé parce que fait Emmaüs
se sont tous sauf des idéologues je suis
très en colère contre l'Europe contre
l'État contre la mairie de Paris qui
font rentrer les gens et qui ensuite les
laisse les laisse complètement à
l'abandon et j'en veux beaucoup et
surtout à ceux qui en veulent aux
Français parce que les Français puis
depuis trois décennies ils ont accueilli
les immigrés du mieux qu'il pouvait je
dis pas que tout est parfait mais du
mieux qu'il pouvait alors moi en ce qui
me concerne je n'ai certainement pas
honte d'être français je dirais bravo et
la seule question que vous avez posé
c'est est-ce que ça a changé votre
vision du problème non parce que
honnêtement non parce que j'ai toujours
eu de la compassion pour ces gens-là ils
sont ni meilleur ni mauvais que nous ce
sont des êtres humains et ma colère elle
est encore elle est rentrée parce que je
ne supporte pas que je le disais tout à
l'heure pour qu'on expulse pas des gens
qui qui n'ont rien à faire ici ça nous
permettrait justement d'accueillir des
gens qui méritent juridiquement et
humainement d'être accueilli puis
d'autre part je supporte pas qu'on fasse
la leçon par exemple aux Européens c'est
[__] européens qu'on se voit par
exemple des pays comme le Qatar comme
l'Arabie Saoudite qui ont de l'argent
qui ont de la place ils parlent la même
langue que ces gens-là ils veulent
surtout pas faire le moindre effort donc
si vous voulez je n'en je je j'ai perçu
une réalité humaine parce que je je je
suis en communion avec ces gens là ce
sont des êtres humains comme moi mais ma
vision des choses elle n'a pas changé
toutes celles qui dansent la tête des
princesses
et maintenant pour chanzene libre hapsat
aussi c'est intéressant
de capoter la contraception masculine
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
mais d'abord on est parti d'un chiffre
qui nous alerté en 2010 il y avait 45%
des femmes qui prenaient la pilule et
aujourd'hui il y en a plus de 36 donc on
s'est dit évidemment pourquoi nous les
femmes on se gaverait d'hormones et
pourquoi pas vous les hommes donc
évidemment on s'est posé la question de
la contraception masculine et on a
découvert des méthodes très innovantes
et la première dont je vais vous parler
c'est une méthode qui s'appelle la
contraception thermique
chauffant qui
bonjour je m'appelle Erwan j'ai 38 ans
j'utilise la contraception masculine
thermique depuis un peu plus d'un an et
en fait c'est juste un slip que j'enfile
le matin jusqu'au soir voilà ça
ressemble à ça un boulot chaud c'est
simplement un slip que je vais enfiler
chaque matin et ensuite je vais passer
ma verge tirer la peau des bourses et ça
fait remonter les testicules près de mon
corps comme ça ils sont deux degrés plus
chaud mais c'est ça qui va arrêter la
production des spermatozoïdes donc on
cherche à le porter 15 heures par jour
pour avoir l'effet contraceptif je vais
vous montrer comment je le mets
déshabillez-moi
[Musique]
donc là je passe la verge dans l'orifice
je tire la peau délicatement ça fait
remonter les testicules qui maintenant
du coup je trouve ici ensuite je mets
simplement un sous-vêtement par
au-dessus et puis mon jean encore
comment tu te sens moi je me sens bien
c'est très confortable ça sera jamais
élevé aussi bien que d'être complètement
nu maintenant c'est pas pire qu'un
soutien-gorge
aucune raison pour que les hommes se
contraceptent pas les femmes le font
depuis longtemps on peut se partager
cette tâche là avec cette méthode j'ai
la possibilité de contrôler ma
parentalité de pas être père si je le si
je le désire pas
[Applaudissements]
les testicules il faut se laisser les
couilles il faut se les mettre à
l'intérieur du corps c'est ça je
comprends pas
c'est la température qui monte de 2 3
degrés et qui fait justement ce que ça
ça devient une méthode contraceptive
alors ça me fait rire parce que mon
voisin il dit mais enfin dans les pays
chauds ils sont pas moins stériles
moins oui exactement évidemment se
multiplie à vue d'oeil en revanche
ils seront 30 à la fin tu passes un truc
comme ça je sais pas j'ai regardé la
démonstration contrairement à ce que
prétend Hanouna il y a pas que quand il
pète il troue son
slipes de la chanson
et attention il y a un seul médecin qui
le propose aujourd'hui faut pas
l'utiliser plus de 4 ans parce que ça
peut conduire à une stérilité donc ça ça
c'est important c'est efficace de
si on l'utilise pendant deux à quatre
mois et c'est réversible après si ça
neuf mois après vous pouvez de nouveau
avoir des enfants
alors si vous avez été pousse soufflé
par celle-là j'en ai une autre encore
plus spectaculaire encore plus folle
vous allez avoir du mal à le croire
c'est une invention d'un menuisier
allemand elle a figurait
du tout mais comme on éteint la lumière
c'est un interrupteur à spermatozoïde un
intérêts
voici la balmek les testicules
produisent des millions de
spermatozoïdes chaque jour ces
spermatozoïdes se déplacent dans le
canal déférent et se mêlent à différents
fluides ils sont ensuite évacués lors de
l'éjaculation le système bimak est
attaché sur ces canaux déférents le
bouton on/off peut être pressé à travers
la peau du scrotum le flot de
spermatozoïdes est ensuite redirigé à
travers le corps et il ne peut plus
atteindre le sperme
on trouve ça complètement fou bon il y a
que lui qui le porte pour l'instant
personne d'autre le porte on n'est pas
prêt de le voir commercialiser en France
mais je trouvais l'anecdote plutôt drôle
je pense surtout messieurs que si vous
preniez conscience de l'évolution du
droit qui fait qu'aujourd'hui une femme
peut vous imposer une paternité parce
que aujourd'hui il suffit qu'elle
demande un test de paternité et en gros
c'est la femme qui décide si l'homme est
père vous seriez attention
[Musique]
voilà c'était la perle les dernières du
dimanche l'émission qui vous êtes à vous
faire votre opinion on se retrouve après
la pub à tout de suite
[Musique]
vraiment
du dimanche nous sommes le retour sur
Terre dans l'émission qui vous êtes à
vous faire votre opinion et maintenant
madame messieurs on repasse en zone
libre c'est la France citoyenne par
Natacha Polony
[Musique]
alors le sucre le sucre serait plus
addictif que le cocaïne c'est la thèse
stupéfiante qu'avance de nombreux
chercheurs alors Natacha la poudre
blanche est-elle devenue LE NOUVEL ORDRE
noir vous savez combien vous consommez
de sucre par an moi beaucoup
vous allez me dire voilà c'est facile il
y en a là-dedans les gâteaux les bonbons
voilà tout ça et puis évidemment
la célèbre
pâte à tartiner qui contient quand même
très très peu de noisettes et de cacao
50 morceaux de sucre dans ce petit pot
non mais j'adore
et ce truc là là
alors ça dans un verre de cette petite
chose vous avez quatre morceaux de sucré
de mie c'est à dire quasiment la dose de
sucre recommandée par jour donc un verre
terminé sauf que là vous me dites mais
attendez moi je mange pas ça
voilà mais simplement vous croyez que
vous n'en mangez pas mais comment on
atteint 35 kilos par an en moyenne si on
mange pas de ses cochonneries et ben
c'est parce qu'en fait il y en a partout
ailleurs du sucre alors si je vous
montre un caddie regardez-moi ça on est
allé faire les courses pour vous
regardez comme il est beau le caddie
là-dedans tu le bousilles pas parce
qu'on ramène Giesbert dedans
pense à ton diabète vraiment pas du
sucre
dans votre pain de mie il y a du sucre
dans votre boîte de haricots rouges il y
a du sucre dans vos saucisses il y a du
sucre dans votre couscous parfumé pardon
dans le petit plat pour bébé non il y a
du sucre dans le sucre il y a du sucre
il y en a partout donc si je vous fais
votre repas du jour un yaourt aux fruits
125 g hop trois morceaux de sucre 200 g
de carottes râpées un morceau de sucre
et demi un bol de soupe industriel 4
morceaux de sucre c'est tout vous en
mangez partout et simplement l'OMS vous
dit cinq sucres par jour vous les avez
totalement explosé pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce que on vous en met sous
toutes les formes vous savez même pas
même si vous lisez les étiquettes vous
savez pas que c'est du sucre pourquoi
comment ça s'appelle le sucre alors il y
a glucose fructose dextrose malt mais la
sirop sorbitol agave jus de canne
dextrine sucre rose saccharose
maltodextrine aspartame caramel malt
d'orge cassonade galactose lactose
isomaltes manitol et les édulcorants eux
950 tout ça c'est du sucre mais alors
évidemment l'aspartame est un sucre est
un faux sucre
quand même et tous les autres sont des
sucres vrai sucre dont certains sont des
sirops de sucre des sirop de glucose des
sirops de maïs etc qui sont en fait
beaucoup plus nocifs encore que le
glucose normal et simplement
ça coûte moins cher à mettre dedans ça
vous fait de la texture dans vos
produits ça colore le produit ça masque
l'acidité du produit et ça le conserve
formidable donc on en met dans tout
pourquoi aussi parce que c'est ce que
vous avez senti quand vous étiez bébé
vous en avez dans le lait de votre mère
du sucre et du coup et bien ça vous
ramène en enfance quand vous sentez le
sucre vous mangez vous êtes heureux de
prendre un goûter tout ça et juste un
petit souci là-dedans c'est que c'est
pas seulement psychologique l'addiction
au sucre c'est pas seulement que ça vous
rappelle votre enfance c'est
véritablement physiologique il y a des
chercheurs qui se sont intéressés à ça
mais évidemment ça fait 10 ans que des
chercheurs au CNRS étudient l'effet du
sucre sur les animaux alors il s'appelle
Serge Ahmed il est il a des équipes qui
travaillent au CNRS de Bordeaux et ils
ont cherché à savoir si l'eau sucrée
pouvait provoquer le même désir que des
injections de chez des animaux et donc
ils ont mis pendant plusieurs semaines
un rat en cage ils l'ont habitué aux
deux récompenses et voilà à peu près ce
qu'ils ont trouvé on propose à l'animal
un choix entre une dose intraveineuse de
cocaïne très efficace d'un côté ici à
droite et à gauche on lui propose en
fait une un petit accès de quelques
secondes en fait à une sensation sucrée
sous la forme d'une boisson sucrée
contenant du saccharose alors on demande
pardon à tous les
problèmes
c'est gênant mais ça permet de prouver
des choses et en particulier ça à savoir
que toutes les minutes votre a et ben
tout simplement il a choisi et sa cam
c'est le sucre voilà comme les drogues
le sucre va activer le système de
récompense les mêmes neurones dans le
cerveau qui
imaginaire la sensation de plaisir c'est
à dire les neurones dopaminergiques mais
qui également lorsqu'ils sont à stimuler
c'est une redonne envie de renouveler
cette expérience de plaisir d'accord et
là si on continue à l'expérience il le
ferait pendant peut-être deux heures
trois heures sans interruption alors ce
qu'il faut dire est-ce qu'on pourrait
dire que finalement la consommation
naturelle honnête nous apportons déjà
suffisamment de sucre on n'a pas besoin
d'en manger en plus si vous prenez
tu peux en manger un petit peu le
problème c'est que tu as vu que tout ça
est contenu dans des produits
industriels et la conséquence c'est quoi
la conséquence ce sont des diabètes il
faut savoir que aujourd'hui le
département en France où il y a le plus
de diabète c'est la scène Saint-Denis
mais oui et vous avez en France 3,5
millions de diabète ce sont les pauvres
qui payent c'est-à-dire ceux qui se
nourrissent de ces cochonneries et
dernier point le diabète ça rapporte à
qui au laboratoire pharmaceutique
formation
2016 le ça a rapporté les produits
anti-diabétiques est-ce qu'on peut
encore écouter zucchero
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant pour sciences de libre
c'est la France qui se lève tôt c'est
Raquel Garrido alors où beaucoup d'usine
délocalisent et ferme leur porte
certains ouvriers résistent c'est le cas
de ceux de fralibes il y a 7 ans ils se
sont battus contre le géant Unilever à
l'heure actuelle que sont-ils devenus je
suis allée voir reprendre des nouvelles
parce que c'est lutte qu'on a tous
entendu parler mais j'avais pas entendu
récemment des nouvelles de leur
œuvre et donc je suis allé leur poser la
question
je suis à Gémenos dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône pour rendre visite à
des héros ils ont résisté pendant
1336 jours contre un géant de
l'industrie agroalimentaire Unilever qui
voulait délocaliser l'usine en Pologne
ici en fabrique du thé aromatisé et
suite à leur résistance et leur
combativité les salariés ont gardé leur
usine ils en sont devenus les
propriétaires sous la forme d'une
coopérative ils sont devenus leur propre
patron donc on va aller leur rendre
visite
[Applaudissements]
ainsi une journée extraordinaire qu'on
avait vécu là
[Musique]
parce qu'on savait que notre usine a été
profitable et rentable et des
travailleurs lambda pouvaient prendre en
main leur destin malgré les pressions
malgré la durée malgré l'argent qu'une
univers a mis sur la table pour diviser
le mouvement on a résisté jusqu'au bout
et au bout on a obtenu cet accord et à
partir de là on a tout recréé qu'on est
reparti à zéro aujourd'hui on continue à
monter en puissance pas suffisamment
encore pour être à l'équilibre mais on
vise cet équilibre mi 2018 et donc on
fait tout pour y arriver
[Musique]
je peux vous dire que personne n'est
sorti Inde de cette lutte y compris la
famille et quand les enfants nous font
des reproches qu'on n'est pas à la
maison ici là ça fait ça fait ça fait
mal mais bon on est passé au dessus de
ça
[Musique]
moi mon cas personnel je suis
célibataire j'ai un crédit sur une
maison donc voilà qu'est-ce que j'allais
faire je viens de faire ressaisir la
maison parce que et après j'aurais fait
quoi j'aurais fait comme un certain
impersonnes vivre dans une voiture
non je voulais pas de ça je voudrais
rien lâcher j'aurais rien lâcher parce
que j'étais vraiment convaincu d'être
dans mon droit j'ai acheté un très vieux
camping-car que j'avais posé sur le
parking une prise de courant et pendant
plus de 6 mois j'habitais avec mes
petits chiens dans la camping-car
c'est différent de travailler dans le
cadre coopératif par rapport à le
travail même non qu'est-ce qui change
alors
il y a un bout de transpiration de moi
de fatigue de lutte d'orage qui est dans
ce qui sont dans ces murs là maintenant
le succès
ou la défaite c'est entre nommé à nous
de mettre la tête dans le guidon et
d'avancer d'avancer d'avancer et puis
voilà on regarde d'ailleurs quand on a
le temps
[Musique]
on est fier de ce qu'on dit et
aujourd'hui
à temps ouvrier de pouvoir dire je suis
fier de mon travail
ça n'existe plus nous on a banni
l'actionnariat puisque on a pour nous
enlever les nuisibles de notre société
et donc voilà nous on rêve pas d'être
millionnaire au milliardaire nous on
rêve simplement de pouvoir travailler et
vivre de notre travail
de 1600 euros net sur 13 mois le niveau
de salaire technicien agent de maîtrise
de 1670 euros net sur 13 mois et le
cadre puisqu'on en a qu'un lui on l'a
mis au minimum de la convention
collective ce qui est 2000 euros net par
mois sur 13 mois ce qui fait en rapport
du plus petit au plus gros salaire de 1
à 1,25 alors que pour donner la
comparaison avec une ligne verte à 310
[Musique]
direction ressources humaines et
syndicats alors ça c'est ça c'est pas
commun
depuis 2010 l'annonce de la fermeture du
site de Gémenos par le groupe Unilever
plus aucun site du Niles Auvergne a été
fermé en France on pense modestement que
on y a fortement contribué parce
qu'aujourd'hui le groupe doit regarder à
deux fois avant de fermer une usine pour
pouvoir se retrouver avec un conflit
comme nous on a pu le mener
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah c'est super
tu es un tournage très émouvant parce
que on est revenu sur la lutte qui a
duré et donc 1336 jours c'est très long
et là on sent que c'est positif parce
qu'on sait maintenant qu'ils ont gagné
mais quand tu es dedans tu sais pas et
le nombre d'enfants qui ont passé les
Noël là-dedans c'est extrêmement
touchant je peux vous dire que voilà on
se tournage là on n'a pas fait trop de
Patos mais souvent on a pleuré on était
vraiment dans les larmes parce que il y
a une telle intensité de cette lutte
quelque chose de très tellement
magnifique parce que c'est tellement
facile de finalement lâcher la bataille
se dire allez je vais prendre les Indes
licenciements et on verra bien d'être
que pourra et là ils se sont tous
solidarisés sont restés comme un seul
homme ils ont dit pas un seul boulon ne
sortira de l'usine et ils ont tenu la
garde 24 heures sur 24 pendant
1336 jours et à la fin ils ont gagné on
n'est pas contraint à la délocalisation
parce qu'il y a des délocalisations qui
sont absurdes sur le plan économique et
donc il faut qu'on trouve les moyens lég
de récupérer
[Applaudissements]
la gueule
évidemment jamais content
Gil et William Gonesse franchement
c'est émouvant c'est beau tu vas pas me
dire que tu trouves ça pas bien
je suis
tout aussi ému que vous de la
réalisation de ces mecs et j'adore il y
a un truc que je peux pas supporter
m'empêchera pas de vous le dire et
quitte à cassé l'ambiance c'est
l'effigie du Che Guevara quand on arrive
et ouais non non c'est on parle on parle
d'un tortionnaire on parle on parle
c'est pas un point de détail on parle de
écouter c'est gentil tu es gentil je
suis pas obligé je suis pas obligé de
t'aider à ton artiste malinois on parle
d'un tortionnaire qui faisait massacrer
les opposants politiques dans une maison
à La Havane ça je suis obligé de lui de
vous le dire je suis là pour dénoncer
justement
un portrait de Hitler quelque part
c'est pas grave je devais le dire c'est
fini c'est fini
terminé du samedi du bleu sur les
paupières tournent tournent tournent
aussi
et on continue en zone libre c'est la
France tendance c'est Monia cachemire
alors Mania cashfire vous avez voulu la
jouer changement de sexe
on va dire inversement de rôle dans le
dans l'espace public et vous avez passé
la journée dans la peau d'un macho on
regarde
alors évidemment les mecs se sont
toujours plus fort quand il drague en
groupe bah nous de le faire à plusieurs
girl power on y va salut les filles
[Applaudissements]
on peut toucher ou pas là
et Monsieur j'ai soif
j'avais bu dedans ou pas c'est vrai et
si je bois je vais être enceinte
d'accord
bienvenue dans le berceau du relou
l'univers des frotteurs et des hommes
qui écarte les cuisses
qui fait ça
me déchire
[Musique]
c'est un peu de mayonnaise là
même que l'on pense
[Musique]
vas-y recule recule là vas-y vas-y vas-y
braque braque mes bras
vous vous y prenez mal là non mais c'est
pas comme ça
demande à ta femme de t'aider je pense
qu'elle garait mieux non le relou a une
passion les parcs publics et oui il
adore draguer dans les espaces verts
alors vis ma vie nous aussi on va on va
faire les relous bonjour vous allez bien
c'est pas grave je peux vous suivre
je peux vous appeler bretzel
parce que vous êtes craquant je peux
toucher vos boules
[Musique]
attention vous avez fait tomber quelque
chose vous avez fait tomber quelque
chose
ouais vous avez fait tomber mon cœur
[Musique]
fini les revendications quels ont voulu
maintenant
bravo
alors finalement les mecs quand on les
drague lourdement ils font pas trop les
malins finalement il réagissent comme
nous en fait l'idée de ce sujet c'est
parce que je vous ai regardé la semaine
dernière je mangeais des alpéricubes et
j'étais choquée par le par le débat et
je me disais on concentre trop drague et
harcèlement de rue c'est absolument pas
la même chose c'est comme le tennis et
le squash le tennis tu joues avec
quelqu'un le squash tu joues tout seul
avec la balle et là l'idée c'était
d'inverser les rôles c'est plutôt
pédagogique et c'est montrer que c'est
pas nécessaire de mettre une imaginons
entre les hommes et les femmes l'idée
c'est qu'on travaille tous ensemble avec
pédagogie pour éliminer les relous parce
que les frotteurs dans le métro
de la virilité quoi
on a des nuances elle n'est jamais
arrivé ça me faire draguer comme ça tu
serais déjà enceinte je te dis direct je
joue pas assez avec moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on recommence avec le président
Macron notre amour fou nous en mieux
alors le loulou a fait sa première
galette des rois à l'Elysée un galet
pour 180 personnes ou Teddy Riner tout
seul qu'il a découpé d'une seule main il
est trop fort l'année prochaine il le
fera juste avec le mental à on le verra
à réfléchir et hop la galette s'ouvrira
cet homme potentiellement c'est le Moïse
de la frangipane puis Brigitte en a
saisi une part longue et molle c'est par
là même Clara Morgane du temps de sa
splendeur n'aurait pas pu se la coller
en entier dans le gosier
donc là là on se dit Macron a fait une
galette des rois ce qui est con comme la
pluie ou l'élection de Miss Alsace et
bah pas du tout selon l'AFP il
s'agissait d'une galette des rois et des
reines égalité parité fin du sexisme à
chaque fois qu'un homme est mentionné
désormais on évoque la possibilité
qu'une femme soit là par exemple Thierry
vous êtes un mec vous sentez le muscle
et vous jouez au keno et bien je vais
vous de voir je vais devoir vous appeler
Thierry et Paulette parce que vous
auriez pu être une femme alors j'ai pris
Paulette parce que c'est un prénom
féminin de votre génération
ce soir
Emmanuel Macron dont on apprend
aujourd'hui qu'il a écrit est en jeune
un roman cochon ah ouais ouais alors
c'est l'histoire d'un ministre qui deux
ans après avoir été embauché par un
président le sodomise en beauté et
pendant que l'autre Jean en disant mais
pourquoi France sa place
une fiction
quant à Brigitte d'anciens élèves
racontent qui est en prof au moment de
traiter le thème de la passion elle leur
avait dit se faire plaisir ça fait du
bien de temps en temps mais les Macron
les a connu trop tard il y a 20 ans
c'est déjà qui est Michel ils étaient
chauds comme une galette des rois sortie
du four et là on se tape Ken et Barbie
qui se font des petits smacks comme des
Mormons coin sauce dommage
cette semaine il n'y a eu que des
galettes
alors Christian Estrosi mère de Nice a
fait sa galette sur laquelle il a mis du
mimosa des tomates il avait plus de
sacs-poubelle il a tout foutu sur sa
galette il y avait aussi des mégots de
club
un ongle
d'or droit à deux galettes alors en fait
parité il y a une galette et un galet
on dirait deux roues de Vélib' un
message le lobby cycliste qui tire les
ficelles à l'hôtel de ville contre le
même la galette ils sont partout les
patriotes le parti de Philippe au
section du département 71 et 101 et bien
à faire sa galette avec regardé écrit
présence exceptionnelle de Sophie Montel
énorme star en tout cas si l'ensemble
des autres personnes connues en France
décédées subitement
Sophie Montel à la galette c'est comme
quand on fait la Bar Mitzvah de son fils
unique et que Dolly pour chanter avec
eux phil Barney quoi allez partons voir
nos ministres
[Musique]
cette semaine le Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe a rencontré Alain Juppé
le stégosaure de Gironde qui a fait son
plus beau sourire c'est le seul quand il
est content à donner l'impression de
sortir d'une coloscopie mais même au
musée Grévin les gens sont moins rigides
Mounir Mahjoubi ministre du numérique
après une pause de winner devant son pc
seul souci si on mate dans le miroir
derrière le PC était éteint donc on peut
directement lui attribuer un César
d'honneur Stéphane travers ministre du
glyphosate et de l'agriculture à lui
fait un salon du bio pour la première
fois il a touché un fruit sans
pesticides son corps a fait un rejet il
est actuellement entre la vie et la mort
avant cela il a visité l'usine de
production des cheveux de Donald Trump
alors Françoise Nissan ministre de la
Culture vous commencez à connaître
maintenant et bien elle est visitée un
centre culturel le 16 avec une liquide
rouge à fleurs puis le 18 était à la
FIAC habillé pareil puis le 21 et les
parties au Mexique avec les mêmes
fringues et là un haut en tout à la fois
un de plus que les filles Playboy alors
bien sûr ça a commencé à sentir a donc
elle s'est changée et à visiter une
bibliothèque alors nous on va au Mexique
on se retrouve à Cancun à sniffer du
poppers en poudre dans l'arrêt des
fesses de prostituée un filmé par
Bernard de la Villardière pour enquête
exclusive alors Bruno Le Maire Édouard
Philippe et leurs deux enfants Darmanin
et Griveaux se sont eux fait filmer en
train de marcher à Paris un pas le choix
niago a bloqué la ville donc c'était
soit ça soit arrivé à l'Assemblée à
Pâques à Paris on voit des types en
pleine attaque cardiaque rampé vers
l'hôpital en criant ça va toujours plus
vite qu'avec un Hubert
Florence Parly ministre des Armées
s'est-elle rendue à Abu Dhabi où elle a
rencontré le chèque Mohamed benzaied
al-ayan que pour faire plus simple elle
a appelé gros
Flessel ministre des Sports s'est rendu
en Chine il voyage tous où est la
visiter le décathlon de Shanghai c'est
la seule à stopper 11h30 d'avion pour
avoir la même vie pourrie que nous le
samedi après-midi
alors
cette semaine on a parlé harcèlement
sexuel avec Jean Lassalle accusé d'avoir
mis une main aux fesses d'une dame et
qui ne se souvient ni du moment ni du
lieu ni du geste se souvient pas non
plus de ce que sont les faits ni les
mains enfin c'était l'anniversaire cette
semaine du chroniqueur télé et Florian
Philippot le roi du couscous Mister
Garbit qui a soufflé ses bougies alors
que les femmes écoutaient
faisaient des youyou il est passé
directement du FN à la nuit du Ramadan
assez peu un grand écart c'est un
écartellement Philippot c'est chef
Florian alors voilà c'était une semaine
sur la terre salam aleykoum comme dirait
Philippe
[Applaudissements]
ici la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
l'émission qui vous êtes à vous faire
votre opinion on se retrouve après la
butte à tout de suite
[Musique]
dimanche soir les Terriens du dimanche
et maintenant on passe à la preuve par
l'image
[Musique]
alors c'est officiel les Jeux Olympiques
donc auront lieu à Paris en 2024 ce que
les Parisiens ne savaient pas encore
c'est qu'une piste de karting va
traverser les beaux quartiers de la
capitale vous me croyez pas c'est la
preuve par l'image
[Musique]
donc vous me signez s'il vous plaît
disons vous êtes d'accord pour le
commencement des travaux
pour compter un an pour les travaux
après vous pouvez revenir pour visiter
le site mais
jusqu'aux Jeux Olympiques voilà c'est
les travaux quoi la terrasse à
l'extérieur c'est uniquement en été ou
comptez l'enlever
[Applaudissements]
ça va poser problème comme je vous ai
dit on va au goudronner la l'avenue
parce que les kartings sur les pavés
c'est pas paris-rouet quoi et le karting
aux Jeux Olympiques bah oui c'est les
nouvelles disciplines
ah non les parking tout ça c'est bien
toutes les voitures tout ça il y a plus
rien qui reste vous avez pas une petite
porte ou vous pouvez faire rentrer les
gens par derrière alors ce que celle-là
sera condamné celle là aussi les deux
qui donnent sur l'avenue c'est condamné
par contre si vous avez une entrée de
service
alors piste de karting quartier étoile
ternes
ah mais bien sûr avec plaisir madame au
moins comme ça vous êtes couvertes et
vous commencez déjà à ranger les
chaussures un peu tout ça vous avez de
la chance madame nous on va virer tous
les fleuristes qui sont sur la place
vous vous avez de la chance vous serez
sur le côté par contre il y aura des
murs antibruit vous imaginez bien que le
karting ça va toute la journée
oui très bien on laissera une petite
entrée il y a des petites entrées qui
font comme les entrées de chantier
vraiment les magasins fermés
qui paye la perte d'exploitation c'est
la première vulgairement c'est pas leur
problème
c'est pas tout le temps
si on va pas fermer le magasin parce que
il y a 3 couillons qui vont faire du
karting tous les emplois qui vont être
créés grâce aux JO vous imaginez ça ah
pardon vu la Fluence qui va y avoir moi
ça va faire quoi non mais faudrait vous
reconvertir dans dans dans une autre
branche oui
moi je vous demande juste une petite
signature disant que vous actez bien que
les travaux vous commencez vous êtes
d'accord non non
si vous refusez de signer est-ce que
vous pouvez me signer un papier disons
que vous refusez de signer
dites-vous qu'avec la les Jeux
Olympiques les commerçants qui vont
rester ils vont s'en mettre dans les
prochains vous voulez rester ouvert vous
ça c'est sûr donc faudra faire un petit
effort on est avec l'équipe on est posé
juste là il y a le matériel tout ça qui
commence à être posé là ouais ouais si
vous voulez faire déjà par exemple
aujourd'hui un petit effort pour midi et
offrir de pizza pour l'équipe
par contre il y a des il y a des
africains mais pas de cochon dedans que
du fromage d'accord et merci on appelle
ce numéro et je ferai pas si le message
vous avez fait un petit geste
merci beaucoup et bon courage les amis
allez au revoir
Anthony espejo c'est super bravo bravo
bon c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est Jeux Olympiques finalement
ça fait chier quoi enfin ça fait chier
ça fait pas chier en même temps c'est
bien pour la France je crois qu'on est
tous partagés dans cette histoire on
nous raconte des conneries puis en même
temps
plus de bouchons dans Paris vous dites
quoi c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible
et maintenant on passe au winner de
l'actu qui remportera l'ours rouge le
petit ourson ah il est beau c'est le
winner de l'actu
[Musique]
alors Laurent ok bien parti pour
remporter la présidence des républicains
à quelle méthode a-t-il avoué avoir eu
recours pour paraître plus crédible
on attend toutes les réponses s'il vous
plaît engagé un coach vocal pour prendre
un accent plus populaire il s'éteint les
cheveux pour paraître plus vieux il
portait une parka rouge pour qu'on
l'identifie mieux
[Applaudissements]
c'est de l'antisémitisme
vous le savez Florian Philippot a quitté
le FN dans un article récent du monde en
apprend que ce dernier donnait à Marine
un surnom plutôt original je l'ai déjà
quel est ce surnom ma chérie Marina
banana Boucle d'Or soeurette le Keyser
[Musique]
Mustapha et ben j'ai envie de te dire ce
que j'aime chez toi Thierry c'est que tu
es mon chéri c'est ça
merci beaucoup
quel est actuellement la ville la plus
dangereuse du monde pour les femmes
Bobigny le Caire
Mexico
Kinshasa ou Hollywood
j'ai pas arrêté j'ai pas arrêté de taper
au début j'ai tapé à la fin
j'ai envie de dire Bobigny
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça recommence ça recommence je pense que
ça tout est victime de clichés sur la
banlieue
a circulé sur le Net cette semaine une
pétition pour la levée du secret
concernant les extraterrestres une
pétition réclamant le retour de Barack
Obama une pétition réclamant le retour
de la fessée à l'école ou une pétition
demandant à Dieu le retrait de la mort
de Jean Rochefort
excuse-moi tu t'appelles Mustapha
excusez-moi si on peut parler dans le
ecoute
parler
on se respecte nous ne sommes pas des
animaux il s'agit bien évidemment de
Jean Rochefort merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
jeune
[Musique]
tu as raison comment s'appelle le préfet
de police de Paris qu'on a beaucoup vu
lors des commémorations des attentats
aux côtés d'Emmanuel Macron
Francis Cabral
Michel Delpech
Bernard laveillée
Michel bergère ou Alain souchian
o
[Musique]
pêche
comment vous savez
plein de choses je sais pas bon alors
attention qui a dit avec ma petite fille
on écoute du rap dans la voiture
Brigitte Macron
Catherine Deneuve
André Rieu ou Franz Olivier Giesbert
tu as eu les réponses ou quoi ah non pas
du tout
tu es juste un vrai
presque se justifier quoi il s'excuser
de gagner mais c'est dingue bien
d'après le livre de Michael Wolf
consacré à Donald Trump pourquoi ce
dernier aime manger chez McDonald's pour
garder la ligne par patriotisme
économique parce qu'il déteste manger
avec un couteau et une fourchette ou
pour ne pas être empoisonné
[Musique]
parce qu'il va dans des McDo sans
prévenir et il est sûr que la
reconnaître que c'est pas con quel rêve
a réalisé Martina Adam c'est tellement
de 29 ans
elle a épousé son cochon d'inde
elle est devenue noire
elle a eu le droit d'appeler son fils
Adolphe où elle a joué au ping-pong avec
Angela Merkel
elle a utilisé son cochon d'inde
[Musique]
elle est devenue noire
[Applaudissements]
des injections de mélanine pour changer
la couleur de sa peau plus un complément
pour bronzer voilà et donc
Front national isérois Franck sinnésie
il a été condamné cette semaine à deux
mois de prison avec sursis alors de
fichiers les prénoms des enfants pour
établir des statistiques
unique et religieuse de récupérer les
dents en or des Roms pour les nourrir et
les loger
d'interdire la propagande encourageant
l'homosexualité ou de fichiers les
chiens grâce à leur ADN pour tracer les
déjections canines non ramassées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
émission qui vous êtes à vous faire
votre opinion merci à tous ceux qui
m'ont aidé à faire c'est que l'émission
a commencé par ces 26 ans à samedi
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu